اطرحت منصه استطلاع مسوده جديده للائحه
حمايه حقوق المسافرين من 29 ماده تبين من
خلالها التزامات المسافر والناقل الجوي
والاعلانات واسعار تذاكر الطيران ياتي من
ابرزها مبدا الشفافيه الذي يلزم الناقل
الجوي بايضاح المعلومات اللازمه المتعلقه
باتمام عمليه الحجز وفقا لعقد النقل الجوي
المعلومات المتعلقه ايضا باليه معالجه
تاخير الرحلات او الغائها او رفض الاركاب
او تاخر الامتعه او تلفها بالاضافه الى
الاعلان عن مكونات سعر التذكره بشكل واضح
وغير مضلل
من جديد او من جده عفوا ينضم الينا المعتز
بالحسن امير الخبير في اداره وتشغيل
المطارات حياك الله يا معتز
خالد حياك الله واشكرك على الاستضافه وش
الجديد في اللائحه
والله بدايه اول شيء اشكركم على الاستضافه
ونبارك لانفسنا ونفخر بنجاح ذره موسم
العمره لهذا العام وما تحقق من الارقام
باستثنائيه والتي جاءت بفضل الله ثم
توجيهات القياده الرشيده حفظ الله ومتابعه
معالي وزير النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه ومع
الرئيس الهيئه وحرص جميع الجهات ذات
العلاقه على نجاح موسم العمره وخدمه
الرحمن اما على سؤالك الله يبارك فيك
خلينا بس من اصل لمساله معينه استاذ خالد
انه هذه اللوائح الخاصه بحمايه حقوق
المسافرين موجوده من دون نشات الطيران
وذلك عبر التشريحات التشريعات واللوائح
الدوليه سواء او اياته وفق معايير دوليه
ابرزها اتفاقه اتفاقيه مونتريال طبعا لا
يخفى عليك استاذ خالد ولا على سمع الساده
المشاهدين انه التحديث اللائحه لحقوق
المسافرين الخاصه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه كان اخر تحديث لها 2017 ميلاديه
لكن مع النهضه الشامله في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وفقت لرؤيه الملهم
وخاصه يخص بالذكر الاستراتيجي الوطني
لقطاع النقل للطيران المدني التوسع
والاستراتيجيه ما تطمح لهم 330 مليون
مسافر 250 وجهه العديد
جدا انه الناس تعرف انه التحديث اللائحه
ما جاء كذا اعتباطن ترى هذا عمل يعني تم
على مدى خمس سنوات وكان اهم عيار لها انها
تكون
معتمده فيها على تجربه المسافر خلينا
نتكلم على ابرز التغييرتين تم لا يحاول
لابد ان ننوه على نقطه اهم انه هذه
التعديلات تعتبر مسوده الان وليست نهائيه
وهي تم نشرها على زي ما تفضلت على منصه
استطلاع لاخذ المستهلكين المستفيدين
وتنتهي بتاريخ 23/5 ومن ثم يتم عرضه على
مجلس اداره الهيئه ابرز الملام انا ارخصها
في اربع نقاط للنا هي اللي تلامس حاجه
المستهلكه والمسافر انه في اضافه لماده
تعالج تقديم اوقات الرحلات لتكون
وفقنا بسرعه معتز ما عندنا وقت طويل
الموضوع
كان عندنا سابقا في اللائحه السابقه بس
ماده تعالج تاخير الرحلات تمام لكن الان
استحدثوا ماده تعالج تقديم اوقات الرحلات
يعني في بعض الاحيان يجيك راكب يتفاجا انه
حجم الساعه اربعه يلاقي الرحله تقدمت
للساعه ثلاثه ففي ماده الان تم اضافتها في
هذا الموضوع
تعالجها وفق المواد كيف تعالجها
اوكي في خلينا نقول
هي سابقا
كانت ثلاثه الى سته ساعات بقيمه 20 وحده
وحده حقوق سحب طبعا يسال عن وحده حقوق صعب
السحب هي معيار نقدي
اللي هي وحده بديله للعملات وفق اتفاقيه
سابقا كان ما يتعدى 20 وحده حقوق سحب بما
يعادل تقريبا 100 ريال الان في حاله
التاخير من ثلاثه الى ست ساعات يحسب بقيمه
خمسين وحده سحب بما يعادل 260 ريال تقريبا
هذه من ثلاثه الى ست ساعات في حال تاخر
الرحله من سته ساعات واكثر يتم
التعويض بقيمه 150 وحده حقوق سحب بما
يعادل 860 ريال اضافه لما كان سابقا اللي
هو من تقديم الرعايه من مرطبات ووجبات
وسكن فندقي هذه موجود زي ما هي لكن
بالاضافه لذلك الان في تعويضات ماديه بما
يخص التاخير لما ذكرنا 260 ريال او من ست
ساعات واكثر بقيمه 860 ريال هذه نفسها في
حاله تاخير ايضا في حال تقديم اوقات
الرحلات عن طريق
اذا كانت يعني خلاف ما هو موجود في الحجز
في ماده ثانيه في اول كان في ماده صحيح
كانت في حمايه حقوق المسافرين انه لا يجب
على
الناقل الجوي
التاخر على المدرج الان في ماده محطوطه
انه
ماده تعالج حاله تاخير يعني جلست ساعه
واكثر الان في المدرج بدون ما تقلع
الطائره شلون سريعه عادي برضو الان تعوض
زي ما يتعوض في موضوع الغاء الرحلات على
نحو التالي خليني اعطيك هذا الموضوع عندنا
تعويض الغاء الرحلات على نحو التالي اول
كان التعديل واحد وكان موحد لكن الان
الغاء الرحلات صار عندك من 60 يوم الى 14
يوم يحقق استرداد قيمه التذكره بالاضافه
الى تعويض 50% الان ايضا من 14 يوم الى 24
ساعه يحق استرداد التذكره بالاضافه لتعويض
75% من قيمه التذكره اقل من 24 ساعه يحقق
استراد قيمه التذكره بالاضافه لتعويض 150%
قيمه ومن اللي بيضمن تنفيذ هذا
عندنا
انه تنفذ هذه اللوائح احنا ما نحتاج لوائح
اعتقد احنا نحتاج جهه تراقب وبالتالي
تعطيه حق تعطي الحق لشركه او تعطي الحق
كذلك للمستفيد فانا هذا اللي احتاجه الان
انه هذه اللوائح تنفذ وتضمن للجهه ان اصل
الى الى حقوقي فيها
زي ما قلت لك الضامن بعد الله سبحانه
وتعالى هي اللي هي العامه للطني ولولا
اهتمام بهذا الموضوع لما ابرز والهيئه مو
كانت هي الضامن سابقا صحيح لكن زي ما قلت
لك الان خلينا نقول لك نقطه متعلق بهذا
الموضوع عشان اثبت لك انه الهيئه الان في
طور التغيير اول كانت دور الهيئه مختلط ما
بين التشغيل
والتشريع لكن في الوقت الحالي من واحد
واحد عام 23 انفصلت الهيئه عن اي دور
تشغيل في اي مطار مطارات المملكه وصار
دوره تشغيل معتمد على الشركات سواء شركه
مطارات جده او شركه مطارات القابضه او
شركه تجمع الثاني او ما الى ذلك لكن الان
صار دورها تنظيمي تشغيل فقط
ابدا يجب تقديم سكن فندقي ومواصلات منه
الى المطار لكل مسافر اذا تجاوزت مده
تاخير ست ساعات اول كان ثلاث ساعات
وبيوصلوني الى فندق مش معقول
اكيد بس النقطه الان اللي اضافت يا اخوي
خالد انا حقيقه الان زي ما بقول محايد انا
لا اله الا هو يتكلم بصفتي كمختص في هذا
المجال لما انت تشوف انه في اضافه
لموضوع السكن والتقديم الرعايه والفندق
الى ذلك لانه صار الان في زي الغرامه لما
يكون في عندك خمسين وحده
حقوقك صح في من ثلاثه الى سته ساعات بقيمه
260 ريال وبعدها يتم حساب 150 بقيمه 860
ريال يعني اطلع المسافر او المستهلك
بالاضافه الى الرعايه والمرطبات والوجبات
والسكن يطلع ايضا عن كل يوم
260 ريال
لا حقيقه
انه لما تدخل في التفاصيل لهذه الامور
تلاقي انه في نقله نوعيه صريحه على مجال
من مجال الاستراتيجي على التطبيقي وعلامه
تنظيمي حقيقه يعني لا يعني لا نكون
متشائمين ولا نكون متفائلين زياده على
اللزوم وانما متفائلين
ههه اشكرك
قولي يا سيدي
المشاهدين كمان استفسروا خير على موضوع
الامتعه هو موضوع الامتعه شيء كبير موضوع
شيء كبير الان
هل تعلمت شنطه فتعادل 180 148 وحده سحب
مما عدد ثمانيه ريال في اليوم الاول يوم
الثاني يوم 60 وحده يعني تزيد
لعلمك ترى تعرف انه اتفاقيه مونتريال لا
تتعدى 1200 لكن المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وفق الاستراتيجي وفقا
اللائحه الجديده تعوض باكثر من ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لكم
بلا هذه المشاكل كلها الله يعطيك الصحه
والعافيه